beautiful
[Applause]
an emotional moment for both Hallie
Bailey and this little mermaid fan at
the most magical place on Earth Disney
World oh my God
Hallie who plays Ariel in Disney's
live-action version of The Little
Mermaid posted the special moment on
Instagram
yeah
oh my God the actress even reveals her
connection with the young fan was so
strong it made me cry she just hugged me
so tight
[Music]
oh my gosh you want to smile take a
picture
yeah that's the power of Disney Magic
wish
[Music]
part of that world foreign
how has it been watching all these
reactions to The Little Mermaid it's
been really
really whelming I was so emotional when
I see all the babies
it made me cry you did it yeah okay how
excited are you for the release of this
and what will we finally get to see I'm
so excited for the release I feel like
I've been waiting for so long so yeah I
hope everyone likes it the 22 year old
is the second black actress to be
crowned a Disney princess and admits
that the barrier breaking role is not
lost on her
[Music]
I cried the other day I don't understand
how this is happening how this is me and
I just it's very overwhelming and I get
really emotional when talking about it
it was the reprise that I saw and that
was a moment where I was just I cried
it's the part of the song the second
kind of part two of Part of Your World
later in the film where she's on the
Rock
I mean that was the main moment for me
but going back I'm just like what it's
crazy
bro I just hope people love it and I
hope my amazing little brothers sisters
cousins my family my community we all
see it and be like you know what we can
be princesses too this is amazing yes
clearly Hallie's wish is already coming
true
[Music]
foreign